[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
20 biggest movie monsters of 2022 let's
get to this ranking
at number 20 we have the Giganotosaurus
on the bottom of this list is the
biggest land carnivorous dinosaur from
Jurassic world Dominion even bigger than
the T-Rex and that says something about
this list if the Giga that is around 50
feet or 15 meters long is at a start
then we are gonna have Giants and Titans
at the end
and number 19 we have gargantus this is
the octopus-like monster that appeared
in the early scenes of Dr Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness and was an
interdimensional monster conjured by the
Scarlet Witch garganus was around 50 to
60 feet or 15 to 18 meters long from
tentacle to technical tips
18. the felbys seen briefly in the
beginning scenes of the Rings of power
the Feld beasts were Servants of the
dark lord of Middle Earth morgoth and
resembles wyverns without the sharp
snout that dragons have felbys were
known from Lord of the Rings to be
around 50 to 60 feet or 15 to 18 meters
long
number 17 Adam Smasher this is a meta
human with the power to increase his
size and a member of the Justice Society
being the nephew of the original atom
smasher he was seen in Black Adam the
movie and was around six stories tall
which translates to 60 to 70 feet or 18
to 21 meters tall
number 16 mantiko seen in the secrets of
Dumbledore the Fantastic Beasts this
monster is a cross between a lobster and
a crab but gigantic in size around 70 to
90 feet or 21 to 27 meters long with
claws that can crush a person a hot
fuzzy shell powerful jaws and three eyes
as well as three scorpion tails
number 15 dread Norris this was the
largest sauropod dinosaur seen in
Jurassic world Dominion even larger or
just as big as the Brachiosaurus another
long neck herbivore clone The Dread
notice is said to be 26 meters or 86
feet long and around 30 to 40 feet tall
number 14 the worm this sea monster was
seen in the rings of power and was one
of the only terrifying and interesting
things about the series it seems to be a
long Serpentine reptilian creature that
is found in the oceans of Middle Earth
in the sundering sea in the show it
looks to be around 100 feet or 30 meters
long
number 13 The Shadow monsters
sit and Thor love and thunder these
creatures varied in design from being a
spider to an octopus to anything they
differ in shape power and size and could
only be summoned by the user of the
necro sword these are entities of pure
Shadow and the biggest were seen in the
shadow realm in that small planetoid
being more than 100 feet or 30 meters
long
number 12 the troll to be seen in the
upcoming Netflix movie of the same name
troll this monster was thought to be a
myth but awoken from the mountains of
Norway to attack Humanity for some
reason we have estimated the size of
this troll from the trailer to be more
than 120 feet or 36 meters tall
number 11 melees from the series House
of the Dragon we have the Red Queen and
she is a magnificent Dragon melees was a
red dragon in color and spots a crown of
large horns on her head and neck she was
a big dragon and was estimated to be
around 150 feet or 45 meters long
number 10 Galaxies this is also known as
the blood worm and was a deformed dragon
that had a serpentine body and a set of
wings on its legs this dragon from House
of the dragon has a head that bears two
carnotaurus-like horns although Slimmer
garaxis is a bit longer than melees
around 160 feet or 49 meters long
number nine the mosasaurus this gigantic
Marine reptile was seen in Jurassic
world dominion and was the biggest clone
specimen of any type of dinosaur in the
franchise the mosasaurus there grew to
be humongous ship sized maybe with our
estimates putting it around 150 to 180
feet or 45 to 55 meters long
number 8 the brickleback seen in the
movie Sea Beast the brickleback is a
large green fish and arthropod like sea
monster with tentacles and large Jaws it
also has a crocodile-like snout with
large sharp teeth the brickleback would
have been around 200 to 250 feet or 61
to 76 meters long
number seven vegar vegar is the biggest
dragon from the series House of the
Dragon around twice the size of galaxies
or melees therefore putting her around
250 feet or 76 meters long and visibly
very old and aged she is pale yellow in
color and the only one without horns on
her hip and which kinda looks like a
dinosaur
number six konchu and Ahmed seen in the
series Moon Knight konshu and Ahmed were
Egyptian gods and could alter their size
with respect to the power they can
possess at a certain point of time they
were shorter than the Pyramids of Giza
putting them at close to 300 feet or 90
meters tall
number five the Tolkien to be seen in
Avatar part 2 the way of water the
Tolkien is a large whale-like creature
native to the oceans of bandora tolgans
are sentient and highly cultured even
having some degree of Consciousness plus
they are linguistic and can communicate
these whale-like creatures can grow to
be up to 300 feet or 91 meters long
number four the red Bluster also known
as just red he is a red sea monster
scene on the animated movie The Seabees
he looks to be just like a bulky yet
slender marine animal with a body of a
whale slash mosasaurus and has a big red
horn on the forehead he is close to
around 4 feet or 122 meters long
number three the Mind flayer seeing a
stranger things season 4 the Mind Slayer
is a massive entity being at least 50
stories tall or 500 to 550 feet if being
translated into that metric it has a
unique body composed entirely of
minuscule particles giving it a misty
appearance akin to a shadow or a dust
storm in the earlier Seasons it was the
main dark antagonist but in the latest
episodes it was seen just as a pawn
number two the celestials and faligar
since slightly in Thor love and thunder
the celestials in the omnipotent City
and feliga the Behemoth who was killed
were among the largest being in the MCU
both of them being close to 300 meters
or 1000 feet in size although being two
different types of entities the
celestials being World creators and
falgar a God just like Thor
and number one the alien Swarm this
swarm is the main antagonist of the
movie moonfall it is a mysterious
nanobot like artificial intelligence
that was responsible for knocking the
Moon from its orbit and sending it
hurling towards a collision course with
the Earth although each nanobot is Tiny
microscopic the billions or trillions
form a swarm-like creature that is one
to two kilometers long or 3 300 to 6 000
feet across
so that's the list I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam